[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Justice League video
HBO just dropped a teaser there's a
brand new series that they're doing with
bad robot it's gonna be a big-budget
Justice League dark series so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know which
other big-budget series you want them to
do on HBO max so we'll just go down the
list here starting with number 5 if you
missed the news this afternoon
HBO max revealed that they're doing a
brand new Justice League dark series is
gonna be big-budget think the Marvel
Disney Plus series with the MCU actors
playing their characters big-budget like
that there have been several attempts to
do a Justice League dark movie the past
10 years just looking Guillermo del Toro
press F in the chat for Guillermo del
Toro's Justice League dark movie the
script from that leaked a little while
ago it sounds like it would have been
fantastic but it was just way too weird
for the last regime at Warner Brothers
now it sounds like they're totally down
for it and they have the same problem
that Disney Plus has right now they're
desperately in need of new high value
content and they just don't have that
much HBO Max is launching next month and
they just don't have a ton of brand-new
content that they're launching with so
it's gonna be a while before a lot of
these really big budget DC series start
happening is the same thing with the
big-budget Marvel series that Disney
Plus is doing the basic team for the
series would be Constantine swampthing
Zatanna Deadman Madame Xanadu with the
possibility of people like dr. fate the
demon Etrigan a bunch of other magic
based DC characters and villains really
we only have Shazam right now in terms
of big magic based characters in the
movies so think more along those lines
more magic based DC people for if you're
not a big comic book reader DC is
literally getting ready to release a
brand new Justice League Apocalypse War
animated movie with a bunch of these
Justice League dark characters like
Constantine that's probably a good place
to start if you're brand new to the
concept of Justice League dark they
released another animated movie a couple
years ago with Batman and some of the
core characters it was pretty solid so
there is a lot of Justice League dark
content out there already but most of it
is animated in terms of live-action
Justice League dark
everybody knows Matt Ryan is Constantine
he's been on legends of tomorrow in the
DC TV universe for a long time now Keanu
Reeves also played Constantine in the
movies a long time ago
you may remember scott derrickson
recently departed the Doctor Strange two
movie at Marvel he did say that if he
ever did a DC movie Constantine was his
favorite character he would love to do a
Constantine sequel at some point
HBO didn't say whether or not Matt Ryan
is gonna come back for the series since
HBO max DC series won't be super
connected to the DC TV shows on the CW
network so I'll explain how that's going
to work three how are all these new HBO
DC series the big-budget one's going to
be connected to the movies and then all
the other DC TV stuff during the crisis
on Infinite Earths ending scene they did
this big montage the multiverse is
Oliver Queen was rebooting it using his
specter powers during that montage you
see a bunch of non DC TV series and
characters it does a good job of
illustrating how all those are tied
together loosely through the concept of
the multiverse in how that's different
from the DC TV shows which are all on
earth prime right now here's that clip
every existence multiplied by
possibility
and spread out before space and time in
infinite measure
[Music]
civilizations rose and fell
across realities grasping expense
[Music]
life a precious gift persevering in the
face of every obstacle
[Music]
until finally
the Age of Heroes was boring so it
wasn't clear from that clip all the DC
TV shows from the CW what we think of is
the proper arrowverse arrow the flash
legends of tomorrow the upcoming
Superman TV show that's gonna debut
later this year now Black Lightning as
of crisis Supergirl and Batwoman those
are all taking place on earth prime
they're deeply connected to each other
they reference each other all the time
there's like a couple different levels
of DC content depending on where you get
it there's the animated stuff there's
the huge big-budget movie stuff then you
have all the different TV shows on all
the different networks that are loosely
connected the reason that Titans
Stargirl swampthing in the new HBO Green
Lantern series are all in different
universes are because one they're on
different networks and two the crisis on
Infinite Earths producers confirmed that
when they started making those other
shows the showrunners of those shows
were told that they would be able to do
their own thing and they wouldn't have
to worry about crossing over with the DC
TV shows if they didn't want to but they
could if they did want to so number two
all the DC shows on HBO max will be
connected from the start loosely with
the opportunity to crossover with DC TV
stuff if they ever want to but don't
expect that to happen a lot best example
is the big-budget HBO Green Lantern show
that will wind up premiering before the
new Justice League series but they
haven't said when it's gonna start
filming just because everybody is on
lockdown right now it's gonna follow
Sinestro Hal Jordan and Jon Stewart over
the course of many different years
across the timeline like the way that
arrow did the flashbacks every season
I'm using Green Lantern movie footage
but a lot of these Green Lantern movie
characters won't be coming back it'll be
completely different actors playing
these characters like Ryan Reynolds
won't come back as Hal Jordan please
don't make the supersuit green or
animated but you'll see Sinestro when he
was younger and a member of the Green
Lantern Corps Hal Jordan when he was a
rookie Green Lantern under him then
later in the timeline you'll see
Sinestro after he gets the yellow
lantern ring and starts to form the
Sinestro Corps in an older version of
Hal Jordan doing the same thing
mentoring a brand new Jon Stewart Green
Lantern but because they're not deeply
connected to the DC TV stuff in the
arrowverse don't automatically expect
Diggle to cross over the Green Lantern
teaser in the arrow finale implied that
the Diggle Green Lantern stuff is
probably going to be handled on the new
Superman TV show that was what they
meant when they said that he and Lyla
were moving to Metropolis
wink wink because that's where the new
Superman TV show is gonna take place
that this universe is far bigger
than any of us could have dared imagine
[Music]
and as for a green lantern HBO and
Justice League dark HBO crossover I mean
how often is there really a reason for
Hal Jordan to crossover with Constantine
and Swamp Thing two completely different
genres most of that Green Lantern series
is gonna be set in outer space anyway so
early seasons not expecting a ton of
crossover with the HBO stuff as for DC
movie crossover it does sound like DC is
trying to figure out its new Justice
League movie timeline and give each of
the different filmmakers or the big
movies their own space to do whatever
they want
I think the flash flashpoint movie is
supposed to clean up some of that but
that movie won't be happening for a
couple of years so I think they're
taking it on a movie by movie bases so
some movies will still be connected to
the Justice League timeline like the
Aquaman sequels the Wonder Woman sequels
but Robert Pattinson zhh Batman is a
good example his Batman movies are gonna
take place in the past and it's not
meant to be a prequel to the Ben Affleck
Batman they're just gonna do their own
thing and sort of set up this new
timeline of Batman in the DC Universe
think of him is sort of an alternate
timeline they could connect with other
DC movies in the future if they want to
in success but for the most part this
first new Batman movie is gonna be its
own thing in the past and according to a
lot of the other DC filmmakers they're
not planning on doing another Justice
League movie for several years so it's
gonna be a long time before we're
talking about that again so number one
what is going on with the movies right
now well the Batman movie was almost
halfway done filming when they had to
stop for the virus but based on the
current timeline for when they're
expecting to start filming again later
this year they will still make their
release date of June 2021 as much as it
sucks that everybody has to be trapped
in their homes and everyone's on
lockdown and everything is delayed the
break actually benefits a lot of these
big movies in that it gives them more
time to rework the script and rethink
some of their creative so that when they
go back to start filming again it'll
give them the time to make the movie
better and I think we all just want
really good DC movies Wonder Woman 1984
was delayed from June this year to
August just a couple months not that big
a deal they finished the movie a long
time ago they're not really gonna change
anything about the movie during the
break Jason Momoa has been hyping up
Aquaman 2 but that movie won't be
released till 2022 so they haven't even
gotten close to starting that yet
everyone let me know in the comments
though what do you want them to do
this new Justice League dark big-budget
series in which other big-budget DC
series do you want them to do on HBO max
everyone's also been asking me about all
this Schneider cut stuff if they release
some alternate cut of Justice League on
HBO max of course I'll do an Easter Egg
video for it but I'm not expecting them
to do that right now
everyone click here for that new John
Krasinski Marvel phase 4 clip and click
here for the Batman teaser trailer in
Easter eggs video thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]